ich hab echt keinen bock auf den kack ich hab den server in schweden genommen
ich hab den server bei twitch in schweden genommen aber es bringt auch nix
bringt auch nix
ahja der chat ist nicht zu sehen stimmt ich hab die falsche szene an jetzt ist der chat zu sehen
jetzt ist der chat zu sehen
Null
ich schreibe jetzt an unity media auf twitter
Leute seid ihr gerade am start ich poste jetzt was ich poste jetzt was auf twitter und flame
unity media das müsst ihr alle liken dass sie sehen dass es wichtig ist
ich hab getwittert
wollte ich jetzt eigentlich das video für morgen zeigen aber das wird ja nix
ist übelst kacke die schreiben jetzt eh nur so nach dem motor schick uns mal deine daten
blablabla Leute guckt mal wie es gleich ins sofa geht in ich 5a video ich wollte
Ich hab ein Windows 8-90-Video aufgenommen für morgen.
Das Rocker halt wie Sau, ne?
Naja.
Gut, was soll man machen?
100...
Ich weiß auch nicht, 120 Viewer für Max sein Internet geht nicht.
The fuck?
Ja, das Problem ist, das läuft immer mal wieder eine Minute oder so.
Und ich mein, ich hab's übelst runtergestellt.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich hab's jetzt runtergestellt auf ein Mbit von 5.
Das Problem ist, mit einem Mbit, wenn ich halt hier Fenster bewege,
wenn man irgendwas sieht, es fun- funktioniert halt nicht.
Seht ihr das?
Oh, von Arsch.
Wollt ihr das Video trotzdem sehen für morgen?
Auch mit einem Mbit?
Einser.
Aber soll man so, zumindest bin ich nicht abgerissen, oder?
Ich mein, das sieht halt scheiße aus.
Nee, nee, nee, ich kann das noch nicht auf YouTube unlisted schicken.
Watch together Raum.
Jaja, man kann die Bitrate während dem Stream verändern.
Also ich kann jetzt testweise mal beispielsweise, also mit 1,5 haben wir vielleicht,
5 Mbit hab ich normalerweise.
Und ich kann ungefähr, selbst bei einem siehst du es hier unten,
buffert es immer ein bisschen dazwischen und guck, guck, guck, siehst du es?
Siehst du es jetzt, jetzt?
Ist im Arsch, RIP.
Jetzt wird er RIP.
Wenn du das Video jetzt zeigst, was sollen wir dann morgen schauen?
Ja, eigentlich dumm von mir das Video hier zu zeigen, ne?
Ich mein, das Video, das Video für morgen würde gehen.
Guckt es euch mal an.
Auf den Scheiß hab ich echt keinen Bock jetzt.
Ich mein, ich kann ja auch nichts machen.
Was soll ich machen?
Das einzige, was du bei dir daheim machen kannst, hab ich schon gemacht.
Ich hab die komische Kack Unity Media Box neu gestartet.
Aber was willst du sonst, was willst du sonst machen?
Würdest du deinen Provider wechseln?
Ich hab meinen Provider erst gewechselt.
Zu Unity Media.
Max, bist du dir sicher, dass deine China-Geräte dich jagen?
Nein, ich hab keine zweite Leitung mehr.
Ich vermute dir auch mal, dass das Problem direkt bei Unity Media ist, weil ich krieg
halt auch zu wirklich Server, die drei Kilometer weg stehen oder zehn Kilometer weg stehen,
krieg ich halt auch keinen gescheiten Upload hin.
Das ist das Unity Media Kabel, übelst voll Arsch.
Das ist heute das erste Mal, bisher hatte ich nie Probleme mit Unity Media.
Das ist für LTE genau.
Ja, was machen wir jetzt?
Ich weiß nicht, was wir machen sollen.
Alter, ist schon wieder weg.
Warum hast du keine zweite Leitung mehr, weil der Scheiß zu teuer ist?
Ich bezahle ja im Prinzip für was, was ich nicht benutze, einfach das Doppelte im Monat.
Die sind eh nicht mehr da jetzt, die Unity Media Dudes.
Was willst du machen?
Multipass TCP, ja dazu fehlt mir ein zweiter Pass.
Ist Unity Media als Vodafone, was haben die davor benutzt?
Es ist immer noch das gleiche, die Vodafone hat Unity Media gekauft.
Kann man bei Speedtest irgendwie einen Server auswählen, der nicht in Deutschland ist?
Kann man da auch US Server auswählen?
USA TV, ok, wo immer das ist, probieren wir mal aus.
Ich will mir gucken, ob es möglich ist.
Vielleicht reicht es ja, wenn ich einen Server außerhalb von Europa nehme,
dass dann irgendwie das so am Arsch der Welt läuft, dass ich zumindest meine GM mitkriege.
Aber es kann jetzt sein, dass es übrigens abkackt wieder, klar.
Hier Kai, Dankeschön.
Was ist denn das?
Ok, Download habe ich dahin schon mal nicht, ja vielleicht habe ich Upload dahin.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo das Ding steht, ist mir auch egal.
Guckts euch an, guckts euch an.
Guckts euch das elend an, ey.
Da müssten 5 sein.
Ok, mal ziehen wir mal die ab vom Stream.
Ok, testen wir nochmal, gehen wir mal wieder hoch auf 1500.
Man, jetzt scheint es ja ganz gut zu laufen gerade.
Stable.
Die Leute sahen, Zugucker, Stufe 2, nein 2 Monate, Dankeschön.
Falls ich was übersehe Leute, seid mir nicht bös, ich habe gerade nicht so das Auge drauf.
Aber scheint jetzt relativ stable zu sein gerade, oder?
Relativ.
Oder seht ihr Einbrüche, also bei mir ist das alles dauerhaft grün.
Gut.
Ja ich habe 1005, aber ich habe demnächst 440.
Habe ich, 440, also 440 ab.
Und ausländische Surfer bringen auch nichts, überall gleich lahm.
Hier nach Deutschland war eh der gleiche Mist.
Ok, ich stelle mal hoch, vielleicht ist es jetzt ja besser.
Also sag mal so, so 2,5 MBit bräuchten wir schon.
Hä? Hä? Hä?
Leute, nein.
Ich habe es, ich habe es, nein.
Ultimedia, nein.
Ok, 2000.
RIP, Alter, RIP.
Hä? Hä? Hä?
Ok, ok Leute, wir versuchen jetzt mal, normalerweise benutze ich 4,2.
Jaja, ausländische Surfer bringen nichts.
Ist egal, das Problem scheint wirklich direkt bei Ultimedia zu sein.
Ich habe auch schon mal hier geguckt, also es ist auch nicht so, als wird man Rechner, sondern nicht viel machen.
Das ist im Prinzip der Upload davon, fertig.
Ok, es scheint halbwegs zu laufen, ne Jungs?
Dann und Mädels und D und alle.
Dann probieren wir das mit dem Video jetzt mal aus.
Müssen wir mal gucken, wie das Ganze ausschaut. Ich schaue es hier mal in meiner Vorschau an.
Wenn man hier ein bisschen Fenster herumschiebt, ob das ok aussieht.
Ja, ich meine, es sieht nicht gut aus, aber es sieht ok aus.
Ach so, normalerweise auch verif vor immer.
Ok, wir probieren jetzt mal, ob das mit dem Video funktioniert.
Also, Windows 98.
Machen andere Rechner im Netzwerk.
Es gibt ganze zwei Windows-Rechner bei mir und die habe ich nebeneinander stehen.
Also ich weiß, es ist als Techniker so, dass man versucht, immer sich Gedanken zu machen, aber ich kriege sowas schon in der Regel selbst debugged, wenn es bei mir liegt.
Und ich wüsste nicht, woran das liegen sollte gerade.
Ich habe nur noch zwei Windows-Rechner und die stehen nebeneinander hier bei mir.
Und der eine war die ganze Zeit aus.
Ich meine, hier guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist doch der Witz hier.
Uploaden tut dann nichts bei mir.
Und selbst wenn irgendwo ein Upload läuft, das bricht nicht so ein normalerweise.
Also diese Schwanken ist halt überhaupt nicht typisch für irgendwelche Sachen, die im Hintergrund laufen oder so.
Guckt es euch an.
Fuck ey, was für ein Scheiß.
Ich wollte eigentlich noch ne Runde Tremson.
Wegen Afghan ist das so.
Ja, genau.
Alter!
The fuck!
MonkaS!
Was war das denn jetzt?
Ist die Audiospur im Arsch oder was?
Alter mein Ohr!
Ich hoffe bei euch hat es geruckelt.
Ich hoffe bei euch hat es geruckelt, wo ich das versucht habe abzuspielen.
Ihr habt es hoffentlich nicht gesehen, oder?
Das Afghan-Video.
Okay, gut.
Das hatte übelsten Bug mit der Audiospur.
VLC kann das bestimmt abspielen.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das ruckelt.
Ich sehe es schon in meiner Vorschau, da geht nichts.
Da geht nichts.
Es laggt und ruckelt und buggt rum.
Kannst du knicken.
Macht ein Unimedia so.
Nichts.
Toll.
Erzähl lieber von meinem China-Einkauf.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich...
Da kann ich auch ein bisschen runter machen.
Ich wollte in China einkaufen.
Ich wollte in China einkaufen, hier im Strema, aber im Strema haben wir aktuell nichts, weil es laggt und ruckelt und buggt.
Mal gucken, wie das jetzt ist mit der Bitrate.
Oh, das ist flüssig. Sieht aber aus wie 360p.
Huge-Quality.
Unimedia bekommt gerade...
Wie siehst du das?
Ach, es gab doch diese komische...
Wie hieß denn noch mal diese...
Da gab es noch so eine Seite. Ist Unimedia down?
Alles Störung, genau.
Okay.
Naja.
Welche Grenzen, sieht aus wie normales Zeug.
Artillery Media hat irgendwas geantwortet schon.
14,3 MBit Upload. Wo war denn Hanoi? Ja, ist ja bei mir hier.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die für Schmerzen haben.
Ich könnte mal auf meinem MikroTik-Router gucken.
Guckt mal, ob ich euch das zeigen kann.
Also, da hat man doch irgendwo so Graphen, wo man nachgucken kann.
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, unter welchem Punkt von diesem komischen Interfaces...
Okay, guckt mal, was so über meine Interfaces drüber geht.
Es hält sich ja in Grenzen.
Ja.
Alter, was ist im WLAN los?
Ach so, ja, das ist das WLAN.
Was ist im WLAN los?
Moment, Rx? Tx?
Moment, äh, nee, vergiss es, kein Ding.
Wobei, doch, Rx. Was ist da im WLAN los?
Hm.
Moment, Schwachsinn.
Äh, ich muss gucken, ich muss gucken Richtung Internet.
Nicht Richtung, Richtung WLAN. Das ist total bescheuert. Das ist okay, dass das WLAN 2,5 macht.
Das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung. Die Frage ist, wo das hingeht.
Ich hätte mal meine Ports benennen sollen. Ich glaube, der hier ist ins Internet raus.
Nee, der... Warte mal, ins Internet raus ist...
F***, welcher Port ist fürs Internet noch mal? Hätte ich den Scheiß mal benannt. Ich glaube, der hier.
Seht ihr, es ist doch nichts von mir im Netzwerk.
Das ist der, der ins Internet rausgeht.
Da ist nichts.
Sayumi Seifenspender.
Sag mal, wie viel Traffic ist bei dir los? Na ja. Drüben wird grad Fernseh geguckt.
Über...
Shield TV.
Warum, warum im WLAN grad so viel Traffic ist, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Aber...
Hängen halt ein paar Geräte drin, ne?
Da hängen die ganzen ESPs drin, da hängen irgendwie fünf Tablets drin oder so.
Und es ist jetzt ja nicht so, dass 2,2 bis 3 MBit viel sind oder so.
Ja, aber das hier ist ja das Entscheidende.
Das ist nicht so viel, ne?
Ich glaube, lass mal überlegen, ich glaube, Port 5 ist es.
Oh, Unitimedia hat geantwortet.
Bitte eine DM mit den Kundendaten schicken.
Hab ich zwar schon 50 mal gemacht, aber...
Machen wir mal.
Okay, ich schick' Unitimedia mal kurz meine Kundendaten.
So.
Ja.
Also, Unitimedia hat geantwortet, ich hab ihm die Kundendaten per PM geschickt, gucken wir mal.
Also...
Unabhängig davon, dass ich gerade ein bisschen irritiert war, welcher Port von mir zum Internet geht.
Aber ich glaube, es ist der 5er.
Also, es ist alles in Ordnung, ja.
Alles im Rahmen.
Wir können es relativ einfach testen, welcher Port das ist.
Also, sagen wir so, wir können es noch einfacher machen.
Ich kann einfach mal gucken, welcher Port das ist.
Vielleicht sollte ich die Ports bei der Gelegenheit auch mal ordentlich benennen.
Ja.
Port 1.
Hast du hier einen Business Vertrag? Nein, hab ich nicht.
Port 1 ist es hier, der da.
Mal uns jetzt den Graph angucken.
Pass' mal auf, wenn ich jetzt OBS ein bisschen hochschraube...
Ich mach' jetzt OBS ein bisschen...
Also, wir warten jetzt erst mal kurz, bis es sich hier eingependelt hat.
Wow.
Jaja, ist klar, 30.
Ups.
So, also wir haben jetzt ungefähr 1,4 MBit oder so in dem Dreh, das ist okay.
Das ist ein bisschen gedöhnt und halt OBS.
Ich mach' es jetzt mal runter. Nee, runter kann ich nicht, dann seht ihr nichts mehr.
Ich mach' es jetzt mal hoch.
Mal, wenn ihr sehen.
Es geht rauf.
Na super, jetzt sieht man es nicht.
Ja, aber doch, guck' hier, man sieht's schon.
Seht ihr?
Das ist der Port zum Internet.
Oh, oh, guck' mal hier, Leute, es funktioniert.
Also, es ist eindeutig, dass es der richtige Port ist.
TXRX, das ist Senden und Empfang.
Transmission und Receive.
Gucken, jetzt sind wir auch hier bei 2 bis 2 bis 3 MBit.
Also, wir haben den richtigen Port.
Was das für komische Spikes sind, müssen wir mal gucken.
Aber ich würde sagen, nicht unbedingt was Schlimmes.
Gibt es Mikrotikrute auch internes DSL? Nein.
Gucken mal, jetzt läuft's eigentlich ganz gut, seht ihr das?
Seht ihr das?
Haha, jebaited, jebaited.
Das sah nur so aus.
Das sah nur so aus, jebaited.
Okay, Leute, jetzt sind wir mal hardcore.
Guckt, es geht direkt wieder rauf.
Leute, soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Also, vor einer halben Stunde war das noch viel mehr Probleme.
Hat Unity Media schon was gemacht?
Der Chat ist über dem Graph, okay, jebaited.
Ist so besser?
Nee, so ist er auch drüber.
So ist, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Komplimatischer ist das Wort, das du suchst.
Hä? Welches Wort suche ich denn?
Ach so? Ach, ja.
Big Brain, Alter.
Hört das in irgendwelchen Received Packets? Keine Ahnung.
Aber Received Packets ist ja okay, dass Received Packets mal kurz ein bisschen,
ein bisschen peaked, weil Received Packets habe ich bis zu 100 MBit.
Der macht halt grad mal was.
Ich glaube, Unity Media hat was gefixt, oder?
Weil es läuft jetzt wieder.
Ich stelle jetzt mal zurück auf meine normale Settings.
Machen wir einfach mal 4000.
Siehst du, geht auch gleich wieder ein Stückchen hoch.
Wie alt bist du jetzt? 35.
Okay, Leute, ich glaube, Unity Media hat es hingekriegt.
Eats.
Was ist das für ein Ding, wo du gerade drauf bist?
Das ist das Web-Interface von meinem MikroTik-Router.
Ach ja, auch noch eine Sache, die ich hätte im Video erwähnen können auf YouTube,
dass richtige Router auch ganz gute, gehört zwar nicht zu den Routing-Funktionalitäten,
aber auch halbwegs brauchbare Analysefunktionen haben.
In der Fritzbox kannst du das vergessen.
Okay, nice, geht wieder.
Schauen wir mal, was Unity Media sagt.
Wisst ihr, was das Witzige ist?
Wenn Unity Media sagt so nach dem Motto,
ja, gar war ja überhaupt nichts, dann zeige ich ihnen einfach die Stremaufzeichnung.
Das ist jetzt ja quasi Live-Unity-Media-Fail gewesen.
Gut, Leute, wir sind jetzt...
Nein, Unity Media.
Come on, bra.
Was ist da los?
Nicht abkacken jetzt.
Wonka Smoke.
Okay.
Man sieht es hier auch, guckt.
Man sieht das auch.
Jedes Mal, wenn der Upload einbricht, bricht der halt ein.
Wenn ich bei mir was hätte...
Also, schauen wir mal so.
Das, was man an so einem Graph schon mal wunderbar erkennen kann, ist,
wenn es an mir jetzt liegen würde, dann würde hier OBS abkacken oder Stream ruckeln.
Allerdings, der Ausschlag von meinem Upload würde am Anschlag sein.
Nachdem die Probleme außerhalb sind, bricht halt der Upload-Graph ein,
weil es halt nicht einfach nicht mehr geht.
Wofür steht DM?
O?
DM?
Hä?
Ich weiß nicht, wo.
Direct-Message.
Ach, du meinst bei Twitter.
Ich dachte, du meinst hier im Interface.
Okay, Leute, wollen wir jetzt Video gucken für morgen?
Jetzt muss anscheinend funktionieren.
Wir müssen die Zeit nutzen.
Ich lasse das Interface mal auf, da können wir gucken.
Okay, also.
Max FPS Video Vorschau.
Ich habe ein Video aufgenommen, Windows 98.
Wir haben ja letztens im Stream schon ein bisschen experimentiert.
Ich reakte nicht auf mich selbst.
Ihr könnt euch das Video angucken, was morgen kommt.
Und vielleicht reakte ich auch ein bisschen auf mich selbst.
Hallo?
So, wir müssen mal gucken, ob die Lautstärke stimmt.
Ich mache es mal im VLC auf.
Warum ist der VLC da eigentlich nicht drin?
Warum muss ich den VLC so beknackt über das Terminal starten?
Big Brain.
Oh, jetzt noch ein bisschen reißen.
Heute schauen wir uns mal circa 20.
Okay, Leute, ich halte jetzt mal die Klappe.
Und ihr könnt euch das Video angucken, was morgen erst auf YouTube kommt.
Vielleicht sage ich aber auch mal was zwischendurch.
Aber in die Mikrotik-Routerspitches nach dem CT oder SF...
Du meinst Q-mäßig?
Äh, keine Ahnung.
Du meinst QOS, Q-mäßig?
Ne, ich habe keinen Schimmer.
Weiß ich nicht.
Oder was meinste?
Und jetzt bevor ich das Video anmache, noch was zu sagen.
Guck mal, wie es hier rumspackt.
Ob es noch rumspackt?
Nein, macht es nicht.
Okay, nice.
Auch hier sieht alles jetzt wieder gut aus.
Keine Einbrüche, sonst wird es einfach glatt.
Wie die schalten?
Was weiß ich?
Keine Ahnung.
Also wenn du jetzt fragst, was weiß ich?
Er rautet.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber das schöne an Mikrotik ist, die haben immer relativ gute Beschreibungen.
Auch wenn es ziemlich konfus ist.
So, also Video für morgen.
Ihr müsst ach so Leute.
Also was schön wäre, wenn ihr mal drauf achten könnt.
Was zum?
Sag mal, brummt das?
Wenn ich mein Handy anfasse, brummt es.
Das ist lustig.
Ah.
Ah, nice.
Okay, wenn ich den Strom anschließe ans Handy, brummt es.
Scheinlich, weil es an einer anderen Steckdose ist.
Okay, sie haben einen Störungsticket gemacht.
Ich werde jetzt per SMS über die weiteren Schritte informiert.
Na gut, schön.
Also Video für morgen.
Jetzt aber.
Sieht alles gut aus.
Also es wäre cool, wenn ihr mal drauf achten könnt, ob das für Leute auf YouTube überhaupt interessant ist.
Ich habe schon ziemlich zusammengeschnitten.
Und eigentlich geht es ja bloß darum, sich ein bisschen Windows 98 anzugucken.
Deswegen, ich habe auch den Installvorgang übelst schnell geskippt.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich nicht vielleicht als Startbild irgendwie mal kurz den Desktop einblenden soll.
Weil es sind alle Leute immer, also die ganzen Noobs sind immer übelst schockiert, wenn sie ein Terminal oder halt ein Textfenster sehen.
Okay, auf geht's.
Im Chat markieren, dass ich sehe, wo es losgeht.
Hallo, Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max.
Und heute schauen wir uns mal circa 20 Jahre nach Release Windows 98 an.
Ich bin mal echt gespannt, wie lautstärke ist.
Hallo, Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max.
Und heute schauen wir uns mal circa 20 Jahre nach Release Windows 98 an.
Ich bin mal echt gespannt, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Ich werde auch ein bisschen vorspulen, weil ich meine, ihr wollt jetzt nicht zugucken, wie ich Windows installiere.
Drei Mal installiere, Spiele installiere.
Gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Auf geht's.
Okay, das Formatieren geht halt auf dem aktuellen Rechner schon ein bisschen schneller als damals.
Weiter.
Wow, es macht Sounds.
Da machen wir das mal im Schnelldurchgang, Windows Installation würde ich sagen.
30 bis 60 Minuten halte ich für ein Gerücht.
Alter, die Maus ist übel slaggy, ey.
Okay, weiter, zack, flop, C, Doppelpunkt, Windows.
Perfekt, weiter.
Pogchamp.
Arbeitsgruppe, Werkgruppe ist gut, weiter, Standard einrichten, Deutschland.
Bam.
Ja, ich muss ja sagen, das geht relativ schnell.
Und wisst ihr, was auch schnell geht?
Den Abo-Button klicken geht auch ganz schnell und bringt euch jede Menge neue Videos.
Das flutscht ja richtig, ja.
Zack, zack, zack, vielen Dank.
Das beste Windows, das es je gab, ja.
Neustart.
Wisst ihr Leute, ich habe mich damals nie getraut auf Neustart zu drücken,
weil ich immer gedacht habe, der macht im Hintergrund noch Dinger.
Aber wir trauen uns mal heute Neustart.
Tests, weiter.
Natürlich nehmen wir den Vertrag an, den wir selbstverständlich aufmerksam gelesen haben, was Sache ist.
Weiter.
Oh, Produkt-Key.
Die Hardware, die nicht placken.
Das finde ich gut, die Überblendung hier.
Nein, nein, ich mache das nicht live.
Das ist das Video, was ich morgen hochlade.
Das fand ich lustig hier.
Oh, Produkt-Key.
Und einfach weg, einfach weg.
Ich meine, es weiß jeder, was passiert.
Es weiß jeder, was passiert, ne?
Es weiß jeder, aber ich sage es nicht.
Für die nicht plack-and-play-kompatibel, es wird gesucht.
Na ja, goodluck, F1.
Er ist immer noch nicht fertig.
Leute, wisst ihr, damals war das so,
ich dachte eigentlich, immer wenn ich eine Soundkarte hätte,
die das unterstützt, also die ihr ja quasi schon im Setup erkennt,
dann würde ich es jetzt hier trommeln hören.
Eigentlich total hängen geblieben.
So, schauen wir mal, ob mein Anmel-
Oh, da ist der Anmelde-Bildschirm.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt alles funktioniert.
Lagenhafte Auflösung, 640 x 480.
Huge.
Okay, Kennwort, 123456, best packen.
Ja, 123456.
Unbekanntes Gerät, da wirst du ein paar finden von,
gehe ich mal von aus.
Ein Standard-Bildschirm.
So, da sind wir.
Fork Winners 890 mit ganzen 256 Farben oder noch weniger.
Es sind auf jeden Fall ziemlich wenig Farben.
Machen wir das Ganze mal zu.
Das erste, was wir machen, ist, wir gucken mal,
ob das Internet funktioniert.
So, was ist das?
The fuck?
Willkommen bei MSN Internet Access.
MSN in 2019.
Weiter.
Modem.
Alter, geh mir nicht auf den Sack, ich hab keinen Modem.
What the fuck?
Nein, ich hab keinen Modem Windows, please.
Okay.
Okay Leute, ich hab rausgefunden, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Ich hab nämlich mal gegoogelt und zwar-
Weiter, weiter, fertig, jetzt, und jetzt.
Oh, da ist der Internet Explorer am Start.
Internet Explorer.
Wahnsinn.
MSN.com.
Okay, gucken wir mal Google an.
Google.
Google am Start.
Google im Internet Explorer 5.
Leute, das Schlimme ist, dass ich mittlerweile in echt manchmal auch sage Pock.
Wisst ihr?
Das ist-
Ups.
Jetzt hab ich zurückgespult.
Das ist übelst hängen geblieben.
Wie kann man in echt sagen Pock?
Das kapiert keiner.
Zumal Pock ja auch schon die Abkürzung von was ist auf Twitch.
Was bleibt denn, was kommt denn als nächstes?
Dass man einfach nur sagt Pee, oder was?
Pee, Alter, Pee.
Pee, sagt man da nur noch.
Pee, Leute, Pee.
Unreal Twitch Prime Pock.
Okay, weiter, weiter, weiter.
Muss jetzt ruhig sein, sonst ist es für euch super verwirrend, wenn alles doppelt ist.
MSN.com.
Okay, gucken wir mal Google an.
Google.
Pock.
Google am Start.
Google im Internet Explorer 5.
Verschlusslungsstärke 40 bit.
Das ist ja bleeding edge Technologie.
Gut, schauen wir mal, wie das mit Grafikdreibern und Gedöns aussieht.
Jetzt bin ich echt gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Okay, das sieht schon mal viel besser aus.
Wir haben mehr Farben.
Die Maus fühlt sich auch viel flüssiger und so schon alles an.
Wir haben zwar immer noch nicht die allerbeste Auflösung, aber gucken wir mal.
Jaja, Startbildschirm, geh weg.
Also es sieht auf jeden Fall schon mal deutlich smoother aus, alles.
Da kann man sich hier nicht drüber beschweren.
Ja Leute, da sind wir wieder am Start.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Windows 98, 1.920 mal 1.080.
Wahnsinn, oder?
Das geht viel schneller, als ich diese Erinnerungen hatte früher.
Okay, oh, die Schrift ist auch größer.
Huge.
So, zack.
Als nächstes kommt der Audio-Dreiber.
Ganz viele neue Hardware-Komponenten.
Ei, ei, ei, was ist denn das?
Ich hab da schon wieder alles voll verdrängt.
Oh, ein Joystick-Port.
Wahnsinn, sowas hat das.
Joystick-Port, kann sich überhaupt noch jemand dran erinnern?
Okay, nice.
Gucken wir mal auf das Ganze.
Neustarten, natürlich.
Was sonst?
Neustart.
Okay Leute, jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit.
Mal gucken, ob wir es out haben.
Woah, woah, alter.
Was ist jetzt los?
What the fuck?
Okay, so hat sich das also damals angehört.
Okay Leute, ich hab mir den aktuellsten Firefox runtergeladen,
den es für Windows 98 gibt.
Das ist Firefox 2.
Die letzte Firefox 2 Version.
Mal gucken, ob wir noch irgendwas Neues zum Laufen kriegen.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Vielleicht noch ein Operator oder so.
Aber wenigstens haben wir jetzt etwas,
was ein bisschen aktueller ist als Internet Explorer 5.
Weil ich meine, wir müssen hier noch Spiele runterladen,
noch ein paar Treiber runterladen und Dinge machen, ja.
Übrigens ganz wichtig, Spiele sind über allem Spiele standardmäßig dabei.
Spiele online.
Monkeys.
Keine Spiele dabei.
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Das müssen wir gleich nachinstallieren.
Das geht ja nicht.
Äh, äh, Software.
Schnell.
Wo? Games.
GIF Games.
Wo war das? Zubehör war das, ne?
Zubehör.
Ähm.
Spiele.
Spiele, jawoll.
Moin, guck mal, der Krieger ist am Start.
Wir machen gerade Videovorschau.
Das ist ein bisschen verwirrend wahrscheinlich.
Aber, äh, das, das ist, das ist...
Passt, Max, der labert im Video.
Ich hab vorhin bei Solution reingeguckt,
wo, wo ihr noch ein paar Runden Beta gespielt habt.
Und, äh, die Leute immer noch
genauso krass tryharded haben wie am Anfang.
Ich wollte nämlich eigentlich auch heute Abend noch ein bisschen Beta spielen.
Und nachdem ich euch da gesehen hab,
bei Solution im Stream hab ich mir gedacht, ne, Max,
keine Beta, ne, das ist kein Bock, ey.
Das war mir dann zu blöd.
Ja.
Nee, die Lust ist ja bei mir schon quasi instant verflogen.
Aber am zweiten Tag ging's dann halbwegs.
Aber, äh, als ich das bei euch gesehen hab,
hatte ich keinen Bock.
Hoffentlich, ja, mir geht's gut, mir geht's gut.
Ich hab jetzt lange nichts mal gemacht auf YouTube,
aber jetzt seit zwei, drei Wochen bin ich wieder am Start.
Mal gucken, wie lang.
Meine Motivation ist ja, ist ja nahezu,
ich sag mal so, der Solution kennst.
Der hat's mit Motivation ja auch nicht so.
Ähm, meine Motivation ist ja legendär, was das angeht.
Aber es war nice, dich mal wieder im Stream zu hören.
Der Max pumpt die Videos raus, jo.
Soll ich mache mal Vorschau weiter,
weil sonst ist das total weird.
Sonst blickt da keiner mehr durch hier.
Oh nee, hör mir auf, ey.
Diese ganzen Glücksspiel-Streams, ey.
Ich verstehe, ich verstehe den Hype darum nicht.
Weißt du, früher, also, als ich, als ich jung war,
war Glücksspiel, so manuelles Glücksspiel
war voll, voll uncool irgendwie, ja.
Alle haben gesagt, ah, Glücksspiel-Automaten,
so übelst, langweilig und wirst du süchtig und bla und schlimm und das was.
Das war, ich weiß gar nicht, warum das wieder so in ist, Glücksspiel.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Warum ist traditionelles Glücksspiel an so einem Kack-Automat,
warum ist das wieder angesagt?
Es ist ja nicht so, dass es, weißt du, wenn die Leute Poker spielen,
du hast ja auch viel Poker gespielt,
wenn die Leute Poker spielen, das ist ja was anderes,
das kann ich ja noch irgendwie nachvollziehen,
aber an einem scheiß Automat, was, was ist, warum?
Und vor allem, was ich erst recht nicht verstehe ist,
warum die Leute dazu gucken, das kann ich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen.
Knerbeer, das heißt Disabo.
Also ich verstehe es nicht, ja.
Also ich habe mir das erklären lassen,
war von einem selbsternannten Hobbypsychologe auf Twitter,
dass das quasi Ersatz, wie nennt man das, irgendwie so Ersatzglück,
Ersatzhandlung mäßig irgendwas wäre,
so nach dem Motto, die Leute gucken quasi jemand zu,
wie ihr Glücksspiel betreibt im Stream, so als Ersatz für das,
das sie selber nicht spielen, irgendwie so.
Es ist halt funny, ich weiß nicht, ich finde es nicht funny,
aber jeder wie er will, ja, ist nicht mein Ding.
Zylaps, Just Subscribed, Dankeschön, Pock.
Also ich verstehe es nicht, was da dran so toll ist.
So ist Glückshormone aus, ja.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, immerhin irgendwas in der Richtung muss es ja sein,
ansonsten ist da da nichts bei,
also ein bisschen Automatenknöpfchen drücken.
Dann, wenn doch Glücksspiel, dann wenigstens noch ordentlich Lootboxen,
ja, da hat man auch was von.
Weil bei den anderen verlierst du im Endeffekt eh nur.
Weil, wenn das nicht so wäre, würden die ganzen Läden ja kein Geld machen.
Ja, dann wenigstens Lootboxen, dann hat man wenigstens noch was von.
Dann wenigstens Lootbox-Glücksspiel.
Äh, ne, ich verstehe es nicht, keine Ahnung.
Sondern wir müssen einen Vorschau weitermachen, weil das ist sonst echt wir
und man vergisst, was ich erzählt habe.
Also, weiter, weiter.
Aber da ist nichts zu hören.
Ich spule mal ein bisschen zurück, dass man auch weiß, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Wir sind irgendwie stehen geblieben bei Spieleinstallationen.
Genau, also ich halte jetzt wieder die Klappe, jetzt darf wieder Past Max.
Also es ist ja Past und Future Max und und Present Max gerade.
Also ich bin Present Max, der Max in dem Video ist Past Max,
allerdings das Video kommt morgen, also ist es auch gleichermaßen Future Max.
Also eigentlich ist das auf ganz neuem Niveau, wenn man das mal so will.
Flex, AT, Twitch Prime, Huge.
Ja, ich mache jetzt mal weiter.
MonkaS, keine Spiele dabei.
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Das müssen wir gleich nachinstallieren.
Das geht ja nicht.
Äh, äh, Software.
Schnell, Pro, Games, Gift Games.
War das Zubehör, war das, ne?
Zubehör, ähm, Spiele.
Spiele, jawoll, ganz wichtig.
Interaktive Demo CD.
Was war da euch Ahne schlimm?
Was wäre mal uns das?
Stell die fantastischen Multimedia-Funktionen von Windows 98 vor.
Na, den zeigt man ja.
Works 99.
Windows Media Play.
Hier, HD, HD-Video.
Microsoft Works.
Was haben wir hier sonst noch zu bieten?
Äh, lustig.
Alter, Leute.
Das waren doch die Zeiten, wo man einen Nexicon auf CD hatte.
Ah, meine Güte.
Atta 99, ja.
Hatte ich damals auch.
Was haben wir hier sonst noch?
Money 99.
Easy Money, Easy Life.
Was ist das hier?
Oh, HD-Routenplaner.
Okay, gut.
Jetzt haben wir uns die tollen Multimedia-Funktionen angeguckt.
Was ist die interaktive Demo CD?
Hört euch das, hört euch das nochmal an.
Dieses, dieses, dieses tolle Voice Acting.
Dieses tolle Voice Acting müsst ihr euch nochmal anhören.
Oh mein Gott, sellt die noch.
Das ist krass.
Das heißt, those progressive
Microsoft Autoroute Express
Okay, gut jetzt haben wir uns die tollen Multimedia-Funktionen angeguckt, was ist die interaktive Demo-CD?
Was jetzt?
Vertrag zustimmen, ich weiß nicht, für was, aber ich stimme zu
Sind sie jetzt zur Installation von Microsoft interaktiver CD Sampler bereit? Klar
Und? Natürlich bin ich bereit
Oh, jetzt kommt's
Kinder eins, was soll es das sagen?
Microsoft erweckt Daten und Informationen auf faszinierende Weise zu neuem Leben
Der vorliegende Leitfaden führt sie durch fünf verschiedene Kategorien mit Produkten, die speziell
Alter, war das cringe damals
Produktivität
Work Suite
Und jetzt?
Ach, das ist einfach nur Werbung
Ich dachte das sind Demo-Versionen oder sowas
Das ist ja
Klicken Sie hier, um zum Windows-Desktop zurückzukehren
Okay
Ja, machen wir, alles gut
Das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst, oder?
Das Ding hat Credits
Impressungen?
Okay, man muss es nicht weiter hinterfragen
Okay, wir machen die Software, Spiele, Spiele haben wir inszeniert, sehr gut
Äh, weg damit
Oh, Winnerspiele, Zubehör
Das allerwichtigste ist, dass man die
Solitär und Mindsweeper haben muss, ohne geht es natürlich nicht
Oh, huge
Big Brain Mindsweeper
Mindsweeper Speedrun
Okay, Firefox wollten wir installieren
Firefox 2, wohlgemerkt
Wir gucken auch mal gleich, wann Firefox 2 erschienen ist
Firefox starten
Nein, wir wollen nichts importieren aus dem MetaDX Browser
Standard Browser unbedingt
Äh, okay, ja ja, ist gut
Weiter
Okay, Google, man kann schon mal googeln
Kann sich da noch jemand dran erinnern?
Das ist das alte
Das alte UI von Firefox
Was mir persönlich immer noch am besten gefallen hat
Das war halt so klassisch
Okay, gucken wir mal ob wir googeln können
Firefox
2.0.20
Release date
Hallo?
Ja ja, fortsetzen
Firefox 2
Oh, das geht immerhin
Das sind immerhin 8 Jahre nachdem das rausgekommen ist
Kann man sich nicht beschweren
Also man sieht, mittlerweile sieht Google aus wie Google
Und das unter Windows 98
Ähm, sowas wie Youtube wird natürlich nicht funktionieren
Wahrscheinlich können wir
Hoppla, dein Browser wird nicht mehr unterstützt
Hm
Wer hätte das gedacht? Nein, danke, wir machen trotzdem weiter
Und Youtube?
Ich meine, man kann Youtube starten
Aber wahrscheinlich werden keine Videos laufen
Gucken wir mal
Ich mein, es ist Youtube, ja
Es wird wahrscheinlich keiner der Java-Skript oder sowas funktionieren
Aber
Es sieht ein bisschen
Entfernt nach Youtube aus
Ich mein, es fehlt zwar so ziemlich alles
Okay, machen wir mal mein letztes Video auf
Okay, das geht natürlich nicht
Das hat mich jetzt auch nicht gewundert, hier unten das ganze Zeug geht nicht
Das hat mich jetzt auch nicht gewundert, hier unten das ganze Zeug geht natürlich auch nicht
Hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert, weil
Ähm, mit aktuellen Java-Skript
Und HTML5 kann natürlich
Firefox 2 nichts anfangen, das ist ja
Irgendwo logisch
Okay
Und jetzt gucken wir, ob wir Wolken haben
Wolken, beste, Wolken, Wolken
Jawoll, endlich
Endlich ist es ein legit Windows 98
Weil ohne Wolken geht ja mal wo gar nichts
Gucken wir mal, ob der funktioniert
Prozess Explorer, beste, sowas wie Starten
Manistrator gibt es hier natürlich nicht
Jawoll, ha, und schon haben wir einen halbwegs
Gescheiten Task Manager
Es ist geil, guckt euch mal was da läuft, es läuft nichts
Es läuft so gut wie nichts
Vergleicht es mal mit einem Prozess Explorer
Und der Windows 10, Windows 10 hat standardmäßig
Irgendwie 150
Dinger auf und hier ist nichts
Gar nichts, was auch immer
Windows ist auch kaputt
Okay, da bleibt nur eins
Reboot
Half-Life 1, da ist es doch
Binzeliert erstmal Half-Life 1
Install Half-Life
Wow
Monkeys
Next
Agree, next
Next, next
Ich hab da grad irgendwas gelesen
Von wegen Half-Life braucht 256 MB
Gut, das war im Jahr
1998 so
Am Ende 1998 raus
Erstmal Half-Life installiert
Beste Test überhaupt
Next
Oh
Ja, ich würde sagen
Wir haben eine ordentliche Verbindung
Finish
Oh Mist, das ganze funktioniert nicht
Woran liegt das denn
DialtX haben wir doch installiert
Tja
Okay, da muss ich jetzt mal gucken
So, ich hab da was gefunden
Nämlich, dass man das hier als
Parameter angeben muss, damit das mit
32 Bit Farbtiefe funktioniert
Ah
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir
DialtX 3D spielen können
Wir können es mal ausprobieren, ob wir
DialtX 3D spielen können, ich habe aber so meine
Vermutung, dass das nicht funktionieren
As of course
Oh
Alter
Fuck, Alter
Das geht mit meiner Maus
Alter, das ist übelst kaputt
Okay
Fuck, was ist mit meiner Maus los
Das funktioniert so nicht
Okay
Meine Maus spackt auch sich übelst
ein ab
Das funktioniert glaube ich nicht so gut, wie ich mir das gedacht habe
So Leute
Ich hab was rausgekriegt und zwar
Man muss als Option noch mehr angeben
Man muss das hier als Option angeben für 32 Bit
Farbtiefe für Konsole einschalten
Und im Window Mode starten
Und wenn man das Ganze im Window Mode startet
Dann, dann hängt das Fenster
auch nicht mehr so doof da oben rum
Wenn man jetzt hier nämlich in die
Konfiguration geht und stellt
das hier ein
Dann sollte es alles funktionieren
Jawoll, oh nice
Alter, meine Maus
Okay, Alter
Was zum
Was zum Teufel ist mit meiner Maus
Alter, das ist doch nicht normal
Alter, was geht mit meiner Maus
Okay, schauen wir, ob das jetzt besser funktioniert mit der Maus
Das ist eine G403
Ich mein, das sollte stinknormales USB sein
Also, hab kein Problem
G403
Prodigy Gaming Maus
Jawoll, immer
immer installieren, come on bra
Joa, wie oft soll ich es denn noch installieren
Ach, dieses Window ist
rumgefrickelt, ich sag euch ganz ehrlich
Gefehlt hat's mir nicht wirklich, okay
Geht die Maus
Wow, die Maus, sie bewegt sich
Huge, Resume Game
Ah, hui
Jawoll
New Game, zack, Medium
Half Life, let's play, let's go
Nein, ich war's nicht
Oh, oh
Huge Auflösung
Ah, das lädt noch
Die Texturen mussten geladen werden
So rumspacken tut die Maus immer noch, aber okay
Kann ich mitleben
An sich, an sich ist gut spielbar
So rumjumpen
Funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut
Die Ladezeiten
sind nicht existent
Erstmal speichern
So Leute, ihr seht's im Hintergrund, ich hab ein bisschen aufgeräumt
und ich hab ein bisschen weiter gespielt und ich muss sagen
es läuft echt verhältnismäßig gut
Ich zeig euch mal wie viele FPS das Ganze hat
Und zwar muss man dafür
Mal gucken, ich hab's mir irgendwo aufgeschrieben
CL, ah ne
Das ist englische Tastatur, CL
Show FPS 1 machen
Und man sieht das Ganze
Läuft so
Na ja
So mit 80 FPS, das die
Die Half Life 1 Engine hat innen Limit
Von 99 FPS
Mehr geht nicht, aber
Ich finde, also ich mein für das
Wie
Wie alt der ganze Kram ist
Also ist das okay?
Ist das Software Rendering wohlgemerkt?
Dass es ordentlich funktioniert
Weil Grafikkarte und Treiber und Zeug
Also ist echt nice
Bin ich begeistert
Lass mal überlegen, was kann man
Alter wie das Pixel
Was muss man hier irgendwie raus
Wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung hab
Jetzt müssen wir uns echt mal überlegen, was wir als nächstes machen
Was könnte man als nächstes machen
Man könnte erstmal Half Life mäßig den Typ zersplattern
Ganz wichtig
Das muss man in Half Life aus Prinzip
Immer so machen und jetzt
Jetzt kommen die Dinger von hier oben runter gehüpft
Warum kenne ich das Spiel
Eigentlich noch auswendig
Was kann man als nächstes unter Windows
98 machen, Leute wenn ihr eine Idee habt
Woa, da kommt was gesprungen
Wenn ihr eine Idee habt, was wir noch alles
Unter Windows 98 ausprobieren können
Schreibt schon in die Kommentare, es gibt ja noch viele
Sachen, wir können beispielsweise
Probieren mal Videos abzuspielen
Oder neuere Sachen zu machen
Oder sagt mir mal generell, ob euch das gefallen hat
Vielleicht
Wollt ihr noch ein bisschen mehr Windows 98 sehen
Also was mich beispielsweise
Mal richtig interessieren würde ist
Videos abspielen
Richtig grandios gemacht, Max
Videos abspielen, gerne
Würde ich mal ausprobieren mit VLC oder mit irgendwas anderem
Und
Auch
Was der abspielen kann
Irgendwie machen wir mal einen 4K oder sonst was Video
Mal schauen, ob das ganze funktioniert
Vielleicht kriegen wir auch Youtube irgendwie zum laufen
Wobei, da habe ich nicht so viele Hoffnungen
Schreibt es mir in die Kommentare, ob ihr eine gute Idee habt
Und ob ihr noch mehr Windows 98 Videos sehen wollt
Ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen
Denkt an den Abo-Button Quickscope
Bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss
Und was sagt der? Meint der so was kommt?
Ich fand es jetzt eigentlich relativ interessant
Allerdings, ich war jetzt halt auch jemand
Der bei Windows 98 dabei war
Gibt es denn auf Youtube noch andere
Leute die Windows 98
Mal gezeigt haben im deutschsprachigen Raum
Gibt es denn auf YouTube noch andere Leute, die Windows 98 mal gezeigt haben im deutschsprachigen Raum?
Das ist doch Alplali, warum heißt der Vic?
Warum heißt der Vic?
Hä?
Die Leute haben mir so ein bisschen, ich sag mal in Anführungsschritten, vorgeworfen, dass ich ein Video dir geklaut hätte von einem YouTuber namens...
Jedenfalls hatte mein Opa so ein Programm und konnte sich...
Wenn es danach geht, habe ich es auch geklaut von allen, die es vorher gemacht haben.
Aber ich habe auf Sex geahnt, keine Ahnung, ob er es selbst geplant hat oder ob er es schon vorher entzündet.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie das wird.
Chill, chill, Bruder, chill.
Na gut, das ist halt ein bisschen mehr auf reines Entertainment gemacht.
Ich meine, ich will halt auch mal ein bisschen was noch zeigen für die Leute, die es nicht gesehen haben.
Kennst du doch Clippy, klar.
Der kennt nicht Clippy.
Er hat schon vor langer Zeit umbenannt, okay.
Äh, weiß ich nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich gucke eigentlich so kaum was in Deutschland, YouTube Deutschland.
Ja.
So, Junotimedia hat ihre Sache wohl in Griff gekriegt, ne?
Wie das Ding einfach mal neun Retweets und 72 Likes hat innerhalb von kurzer Zeit.
Leider ist es jetzt schon 21.20.
Jetzt komme ich gar nicht mehr richtig zu meinem Shima-Kram, den ich einkaufen wollte.
Weil eigentlich wollte ich noch Shima-Kram einkaufen.
Jo.
Also denkt ihr, das kann ich morgen hochladen?
Ich werde, wie gesagt, ein paar Kleinigkeiten werde ich noch dran ändern.
Habe ich jetzt da Probe geguckt.
Ich weiß halt nicht, ob es, äh, also...
Wie sage ich jetzt das am besten?
Man kann es halt entweder informativ zusammenschneiden.
Das habe ich probiert.
Oder man kann es halt wirklich rein auf Entertainment zusammenschneiden.
Dann lasse ich nämlich den ganzen Install-Geschichten weg.
Dann lasse ich zwischendrin irgendwelche Driver-Installationen weg.
Zeige vielleicht noch einen Bildschirmschoner und noch irgendwie ein anderes Game oder so.
Irgendwo Eier auf dem Desktop verstecken.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das merke ich mir fürs nächste.
Wenn es jetzt schön wäre, mein Notizprogramm aufzugehen würde, dass ich was reinschreiben kann.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Mach einen Mix aus Spanien.
Ja, ist es ja irgendwo, finde ich.
Lass man halt auch mal sieht, was das für ein Krezmer ist.
Ganz ehrlich, ich kenne niemand, der Windows 98 nachweint.
Ich glaube, es gibt keinen, der Windows 98 nachweint.
Windows 98 war crap.
Windows 7 war ja auch angenehm zu benutzen.
Windows 2000 war auch angenehm zu benutzen.
Also ich kann es verstehen, wenn jemand sagt, ey, Windows XP hat ihm gefallen,
2000 hat ihm gefallen, NT hat ihm gefallen.
Aber jemand, der wirklich ernsthaft sagt, Windows 98 hat ihm gefallen,
das kann ich nicht ernst nehmen.
Dem einzigen, dem Windows 98 gefällt, sind irgendwelche alten Sparkassen-Geldautomaten.
Denen gefällt Windows 98.
Dem einzigen, dem Windows 98 gefällt, sind irgendwelche alten Sparkassen-Geldautomaten. Denen gefällt Windows 98.
Ja, eigentlich wollte ich aus China noch ein paar Sachen bestellen heute.
Und zwar wollte ich mal gucken, ob es mittlerweile die SATA Port Multiplier gibt für SATA 3.
Ich hatte mir nämlich mal bei AliExpress SATA Port Multiplier nur mit SATA 2 bestellt.
Das war halt hütsch langsam.
Wollte mal gucken, ob es da welche mit 3 gibt.
Und was ich noch nachgucken wollte...
Ah!
Leute, wir waren nicht die einzigen. Wir waren nicht die einzigen, die Probleme hatten.
Bei Unity Media.
Wir waren definitiv nicht die einzigen.
Das ist genau die Zeit, wo ich auch Probleme hatte.
Gut zu wissen.
Wir haben Flup und haben Flup wieder runter.
50 Meldungen sind nichts.
Das sind ja auch keine Meldungen, die bei Unity Media eingehen.
Das sind Leute, die die Meldungen bei Unity Media an diese Seite gemeldet haben.
Und du siehst schon den Unterschied von vorher zu dem da einfach doppelt so viel und jetzt wieder runter auf 20.
Also schon deutlich der Ausschlag.
Also das passt halt auch zeitlich richtig, richtig gut zusammen.
Ja und was ich auch noch gucken wollte, was mittlerweile so eine 16TB Platte kostet.
Oder sind 16TB eigentlich die größten, die es gibt?
Oder gibt es schon 18?
Nee.
Stimmt es, dass man mit einem Glasfaseranschluss viel weniger Störungen hat als mit anderen Anschlüssen?
Oder ist das nur Marketing?
Ich würde mal sagen, das ist Marketing.
Weil, ich meine okay, du hast theoretisch den Unterschied, dass es halt ein anderes Medium ist.
Was aber eigentlich wurscht ist, solange dein Kabel nicht irgendwie kaputt ist.
Bei Unity Media, das Kabel ist halt geshared.
Das Problem hast du mit dem Glasfaserkabel nicht.
Aber Störungen verursacht sich wirklich.
Also ich würde sagen, ob du ein Kopferkabel hast oder ein Coax-Kabel.
Also nein, quatsch, das ist ein normales Kopfer-Telefonkabel.
Oder ob du ein Coax-Kabel hast oder ob du ein Glasfaserkabel hast.
Bis zu dir.
Ab deinem Provider ist es eh Glasfaser.
Ist egal.
Okay, gibt es 18 Terapeuten?
Ne, sehe ich jetzt nicht.
18T.
Oder 20? Gibt es schon 20?
Weil mein Selbstbau nass ist ja immer noch nicht fertig gebaut.
Problem dabei ist auch, dass die Boards halt sacken.
Und ich bin mal gespannt, wann der Gmini Lake Refresh kommt.
Und was es da für Boards gibt.
Wir sind nämlich schneller.
Ein bisschen die CPUs, nicht viel. Ein bisschen schneller.
Äh, ähnlich Stromsparend.
Und ich hoffe, die Boards sind diesmal nicht so total behemmert.
Wie die letzten Boards.
Hab ich mal 3 Boards umsonst gekauft. Big Brain.
Okay, also 20TB gibt es noch nicht.
Also 16TB ist das Höchste, was man sich aktuell holen kann.
Gibt es die in der 5400er-Variante vielleicht?
Okay, wir gucken einfach mal bei Geizhals.
Was ist die größte...
Also der Raspberry ist nicht gut für nass geeignet.
Das Einzige, was mittlerweile nicht mehr ganz so schlimm ist, ist, dass das Ding halt USB 3 hat.
Und deswegen USB und eine ordentliche Gigabit S100-Anbindung.
Dass es nicht mehr ganz so langsam ist.
Aber ich finde, was wirklich das KO-Kriterium ist, für den Raspberry, ist...
Dass das 32-Bit-Raspbian keine Krypto-Extensions von der CPU verwenden kann.
Und das ist ziemlicher Müll.
Die CPU hat theoretisch Hardware-AES.
Aber das geht nur mit einem 64-Bit-Betriebssystem.
Das geht nicht mit dem 32-Bit-Raspbian.
Und das macht es ziemlich uninteressant für nass.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal.
Also Festplatten wollte ich gucken.
Hardware.
Festplatten.
Es gibt ein Fernsehspiel, Betacon.
Ja, damit müsste man das mal probieren.
Ein Progress Stream.
Ja, ich muss das Hardware-Tool noch ein bisschen erweitern.
Falls sich noch einer dran erinnert.
Ich brauche noch ein paar Dinger.
Ein paar Kleinigkeiten eingebaut.
Und das Key.
Windows-Aktivierungstool.
Das muss ich demnächst erweitern.
Das machen wir onstream.
Dann haben alle was.
Also, gucken wir mal.
Datenträgeranzahl eins.
Okay, also ab.
Ab 16TB will ich haben.
So, und dann hätte ich gerne
nur 5400 Umdrehungen.
Das da.
Da gibt es eine Platte.
Nice.
Ach so.
Das sind 4x4TB.
G-G-G-Typated.
Typated.
Okay, dann soll man nur eine HDD
will ich haben.
Was sind das größte, was es gibt
mit 5400?
12.
Sag mal, kostet da die 12 so viel
wie 16 bei den anderen?
Lohnt sich doch überhaupt nicht dann.
Das Screenshot-Tool-Command ist dead.
Das haben wir absichtlich gemacht.
Dass man aufs GitHub kommt
und nicht mehr.
Macht ja preislich nicht wirklich
einen riesen Unterschied.
Nein, doch 100 Euro.
Schon ein Unterschied.
Ich hätte gerne 16TB mit 5400.
Warum?
Weil die weniger Strom brauchen.
Und weniger...
Weil die weniger
Abwärme produzieren.
Das ist eigentlich die hauptsächliche Sache.
Der Cute-Mod, den habe ich heute
noch gar nicht gesehen.
Ich kenne nicht, wo der Cute-Mod ist.
Wo ist er denn?
Wir müssen
Sebaro beschwören.
Wo ist er?
Hauptsächlich,
also wie gesagt, für 5400 wegen
Stromverbrauch und Abwärme.
Es ist halt schon ein Unterschied.
Die brauchen halt mal nur
halb so viel.
Wir können ja mal gucken, was die hier...
Was die für Power-Consumption hat.
Ja.
Power-Consumption.
Idle. Idle. Idle.
Ich brauche es nur Idle.
Was ist die Idle-Power-Consumption?
Idle?
Wo ist Idle?
Jetzt nicht.
Die Power-Consumption im Betrieb
juckt mich null.
Ich brauche die Idle-Power-Consumption.
Das ist das, was mich interessiert.
Vorteil von 7,2.
Das ist schneller.
Also
die
theoretisch, was du übertragen kannst
und hauptsächlich halt auch, dass du schneller
an dem Block angekommen bist
mit deinem Lese-Kopf,
wo du halt zugreifen willst.
Wir machen jetzt die
...
Man sucht einfach nach Watts,
weil die Amis gerne einen S an Watt
dranhängen.
Was ich total behämmert finde,
weil Leute auf die Idee kommen könnten, dass es
Watt pro
oder Watt durch Sekunde heißt,
was auch als Einheit keinen Sinn ergibt.
Aber da hatten wir es ja schon öfters von.
6,3.
Das ist ganz schön viel.
Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen,
dass die so viel brauchen.
Spielst du nachher noch StarCraft?
Das mache ich direkt nach dem Half-Life
Let's Play.
Okay,
4,3. Das ist okay.
Ja, 4,3. Okay, das passt schon eher.
Weil die Ollen, WD Green,
die verbrauchen richtig wenig.
Also Strom verbrauchen die nicht gut.
Guck mal, die brauchen bloß 2,8
Eitel.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Ich muss mal gucken,
ob ich nichts übersehen habe.
Der Zugucker hat resubscribed.
Pock, nice.
Timbo,
er hat auch subscribt.
Nee, nee, stimmt gar nicht.
Ein richtiger Tier 1.
Echt, wo hast du das gefunden?
Also,
2,9 Watt
Eitel ist gut.
Damit könnte ich leben.
Das Problem ist nur,
dass halt die Dinger,
wenn man sich überlegt,
die verbrauchen richtig wenig.
Also,
2,9 Watt Eitel ist gut.
Damit könnte ich leben.
Das Problem ist nur,
dass halt die Dinger,
wenn man sich überlegt,
die verbrauchen das doppelte bis dreifache
von 5400.
Und in meinem Nass,
die Platten, die sind halt
nicht so oft in Betrieb.
Aber ich will die halt auch nicht
alle paar Minuten runterfahren
und ausschalten lassen.
Wollen wir noch dabei.
Also, ich meine,
es ist natürlich sinnvoll,
nach einer Zeit auszuschalten.
Aber, was man halt nicht machen sollte,
ist,
nach 5 Minuten
oder so immer wieder ausschalten.
Weil dann hast du gefühlt,
wenn du das Ding ein bisschen benutzt,
wenn du es direkt nach 5 Minuten wieder ausschaltest,
wenn du das Ding benutzt, hast du dann quasi,
keine Ahnung, wenn du es 2-3 Stunden mal
immer wieder benutzt, hast du dann permanent
die Platten wieder anfahren.
Ja, denke ich auch,
dass es lohnt sich.
Vor allem im Nass würde ich halt keine
reinbauen.
Deswegen wäre halt das Coole,
wenn es 16TB mit 5400
gäbe.
Eine 16TB Platte
würde mir voll und ganz ausreichen.
Ich würde mir 2 Platten kaufen.
Ich würde mir 2x 16TB kaufen.
Wobei,
über wieviel Geld reden wir da
eigentlich gerade?
Na gut, 1000€ will ich jetzt doch nicht für 2 Festplatten
ausgeben, ehrlich gesagt.
Dann behalte ich meine 10TB Platten.
Die haben ja auch schon 1k gekostet damals.
3 Stück
oder sogar einen Ticken mehr.
Kosten die jetzt?
Ja, ich habe 3 Stück gekauft damals.
Das hat auch 1k gekostet.
Dann nehme ich einfach 2
10TB Platten und gut ist.
Ich will es nämlich wirklich basic machen.
Aktuell ist jetzt voll übertrieben bei mir in der
Kiste mit 3 Platten und ZFS und
alle möglichen Geschiss dabei.
Und in Zukunft, wie gesagt, werde ich es ja total
simpel machen. Eine Platte kommt dran.
Und eine
Platte, die nachts gestartet wird
und das Ganze wird gebackupt.
Wird nochmal gespiegelt. Fertig.
Easy. Kein Rate 0
oder irgendwie ein Geschiss. Einfach
Platte, die permanent
dran ist und wird
einmal nachts gespiegelt und gut ist.
Ja, das ist basic.
Platten musst du
bei jedem Nass extra rechnen.
Weil jedes Nass braucht Platten.
Das heißt, es ist unabhängig von
was für einem Nass du kaufst.
Wie gesagt.
Naja, wo wir dabei sind. Ich habe halt noch
kein Selbstgebaut, weil die Boards alles sacken.
Irgendwie. Ich wollte ja
erst zwei Rechner bauen.
Für mein Heimautomatisierungszeug und
für Fernsehkram ein. Und für Nass
und interne Sachen den anderen. Aber am liebsten
habe ich einfach nur eine kleine
Stromsparende Kiste, die alles macht.
Was meine
4HE 8-Core
übertrieben
fette Server-Kiste jetzt macht.
Wie viel Strom
zieht da Nass? Naja, im
Idle wird das dann um die 8 Watt ziehen.
Die Boards
brauchen nix. Die Boards brauchen irgendwie
5-6 Watt.
Ja, das kommt so ungefähr hin.
Also die ganzen Boards, nicht die
CPU. Die CPU vielleicht, wenn sie was
macht. Die ganzen Boards dauernd
brauchen 5-6 Watt.
Mit Stromsparfunktion an.
Mit Festplatte sagen wir mal irgendwie,
10 Watt. So und
aktuell
brauche halt meine fette 4HE
Kiste. Das ist irgendwie schon das
5-fache oder so.
Aber das ist immer noch wenig, ja.
Muss man dazu sagen. Also der Server, den ich
jetzt habe, der ist für die Power und die
Größe, ist das schon relativ sparsam.
Für alle, die es
nicht kennen.
Ich zeige es dir nochmal,
die Kiste hier meine ich.
Ah, die da.
Ich mache es nochmal hier auf da.
Sieht man es doch ganz gut. Hier, die Kiste meine ich gerade.
Und hier vorne
Hier vorne sind halt
3 10TB Platten drin.
Den von mache ich doch auch nochmal auf.
Hier.
Das ist halt so ein Wechselrahmen.
Ja, es gibt ein Update Video vom Säuferraum, weil
ich bin gerade am Umbauen.
Da sieht es aus wie Sau im Säuferraum.
Wie Sau. Also hier
an der Stelle, wo man hier reinguckt.
Wo hier hinten nur noch ein bisschen. Der ganze
Boden ist voll.
Der ganze Boden ist voll.
Hier vorne liegen zwei Mainboards. Hier neben liegt noch
eine andere USB. Da liegen hier
Kabel so überall rum.
Du kannst da nicht mehr reinlaufen.
Hier liegt ein 30 Meter Kabel aufgerollt,
weil ich nicht wusste, wo ich sonst anders hinlegen
soll.
Das sieht aus wie Sau aktuell.
So, aber
ich bin gerade am Umbauen. Ich werde es so machen.
Hier
kommt ein Regal hin.
Zwei, zwei, nennt man das
zweistöckiges Regal.
Hier oben.
Das ja auch ein bisschen Zeug stauen kann, weil
der Raum selber ist ziemlich hoch.
Und ich muss nicht alles
auf die Erde legen. So.
Dann kommt
die Kiste weg.
Wofür brauchst du einen Server
mit soviel Terabyte? Brauche ich nicht.
Das ist ja gerade der Witz, warum
ich ihn weghaben will.
Ich habe mir das ja ursprünglich gebaut vor drei Jahren
oder so. Aber von wann ist denn hier das
Video?
Ah, vor fast
drei Jahren
habe ich das ja alles so gebaut, weil
ich da halt auch
ich wollte einmal eine Kiste haben,
die alles macht,
was ich daheim brauche. Das war damals
halt inklusive Router, inklusive
Nextcloud, inklusive
VPN-Geschiss, inklusive
NAS, inklusive allem.
Und ich wollte zeitgleich noch eine
Experimentierplattform haben,
wo ich ein bisschen rumbasteln kann, so
mit
habe ich hier mal ein Bild vom Server
innen drinnen, mit
PCI passthrough und
alle möglichen Zeug. Und ich hätte halt
gleichzeitig noch gerne Plattformen gehabt, die auch
ordentlich viele VMs laufen lassen kann.
Das ist quasi
Labor und
Heim-Server in einem.
Die Sache ist plus die,
dass ich festgestellt habe,
dass ich mit dem Server kaum was bastel,
weil ich
ihn nicht runterfahren will, logischerweise,
weil da was wichtiges drauf läuft.
Das hätte ich vorher dran denken können.
Dementsprechend ist es auch
maßlos überdimensioniert. Das Ding hat irgendwie
keine Ahnung, 48 GB RAM oder so,
30 TB
Festplatte,
8 Kern-CPU
und obendrein ist ein Big-Wine-Netzteil.
Das einzige, was in das Gehäuse irgendwie ein bisschen
nicht so reinpasst.
Es hat einen
Onboard-SAS-Controller.
Also total
OP eigentlich die Kiste, ja.
Total OP, aber
braucht man nicht.
Auf dem neuen Ding läuft ja auch die Heim-Automatisierung.
Ja.
Was ich da in Hardware plane,
8 Kern-Gmini-Lake.
4 Kern-Gmini-Lake,
nicht 8 Kern, the fuck.
Can it run Crysis, locker, easy.
Ich hatte hier in dem
Pizzi Express-Slot, der ist
hier unten, den sieht man jetzt gar nicht so richtig.
In dem Pizzi Express-Slot hatte ich
eine 980 GTX drinne.
Passt du an eine VM?
Das ist geflutscht.
Das ist geflutscht,
wie sonst war es.
Das Gehäuse,
also die Spiele auf der VM.
Das Ding hat Power.
Wie gesagt, das Ding hat 8 Kerne
und das 2017
zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo
8 Kern-CPUs
auf dem Desktop noch wirklich nicht verbreitet waren.
Da hatten alle 4 Kerne.
Was hat das Ganze gekostet?
Oh.
Kannst du zusammenrechnen.
Also wenn du das komplette
Rack,
also wenn du alles zusammen
meinst,
also wenn man mal,
haben wir mal ein schönes Bild
vom Rack.
Also die
USB, das
Rack, die ganzen
Leisten, der 10G
Switch und der
8 Kern Server. Wie gesagt,
das ist ja intern auch alles mit 10G.
Also das ist richtig, richtig
Big Brain, Enterprise-Stells-Kram.
Äh, nicht wirklich Enterprise-Stells-Kram.
Richtig, richtig gutes Zeug.
Also alles zusammen.
So 3000, na, 3000,
3500 Euro so in dem Dreh,
würde ich sagen.
So ungefähr.
Aber wirklich alles. Inklusive Platten,
inklusive Hardware, inklusive Rack,
inklusive Switch und Dings.
Ja, also ich meine, alleine der 10G Switch
kostet 550 Euro.
Das ist, das ist alles, ey,
es gehört sich jetzt viel an, aber das ist alles
relativ günstig ausgewählt, ja.
Das geht.
Das geht wirklich, ja.
Das hört sich jetzt viel an, aber das ist nicht so teuer.
Ich meine, du kannst, du kannst
dir von Dell, wenn du dir von Dell
einen ordentlichen Server kaufst, komm, bezahlst du 50.000
oder, na gut,
muss dir nicht egal, musst dir nicht die Fetten kaufen,
also sag mal so 20.000 oder so.
So und
die Sache ist halt die.
Ich grade erklärt hab,
dass der Server hier maßlos holt, hier neben
damals noch der billige TP-Link-Access-Point, ey.
Ich mach übrigens, im Oktober mach ich
ein Video bei uns aus dem
Rechenzentrum auf der Arbeit.
Hab ich letztens gefragt,
oder zumindest, zumindest vor dem Rechenzentrum,
irgendwie, was?
Ich hab letztens den Felix gefragt, der kümmert sich
ja mittlerweile ein bisschen um
das Hardware-Budget,
Einkauf-Geschichten auch
und da gucken wir uns mal ein paar
50.000 Euro Server an.
Aber ich kann euch gleich sagen,
das ist nicht sonderlich spektakulär, die Dinger sehen aus,
die Dinger sehen schlechter aus
als jeder Desktop-PC.
Also spektakulär ist das
Innenleben von Server nicht.
Da ist halt ordentlicher Hardware drinne,
aber gut ausschauen tut das nicht.
Also ein Desktop-PC
mit RGB-Beleuchtung ordentlich verkabelt,
finde ich, sieht
so visuell
doch angenehmer aus,
als wenn man in so einen Server reinguckt.
Was hat so ein 50.000
Server für Specs? Kein, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Sie haben auf jeden Fall
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das die
2TB RAM-Kisten sind.
Wie hatten
man einen Server mit Case-Modding-RGB
Leiste drin?
Die hat da irgendeiner, also das ist
noch eine Uraltkiste gewesen,
die noch Leute selbst zusammengebaut haben
bei uns.
Da war so eine Leuchtröhre
drinne.
Case Modded Server.
Ist aber schon ewig her.
Naja und
so sieht es halt im Prinzip aus.
Also ich kann dir die Specs nicht
genau sagen.
An das Dell Playcenter,
die wir jetzt kriegen.
Da kann ich vielleicht was zu sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Dell oder HP Playcenter
waren.
Ja, das kostet
10.000€, nur Refurbished. Stop HP.
Das könnte ein HP Playcenter gewesen sein,
die wir jetzt kriegen.
Die kannst du halt auch so normalerweise gar nicht
kaufen, ja. So einfach so.
Da musst du zu irgendeinem zertifizierten Händler oder so.
Gut.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
ist es glaube ich, was wir kriegen
im Oktober.
Und da kostet
nur das Gehäuse.
Das ist sogar noch relativ günstig. Warum ist das so billig?
Irgendein Refurbished Ding
oder so.
Naja, aber ihr könnt euch jetzt in der Tour umgekehrt
überlegen, was irgendwie so ein Playcenter
mit Plates kostet.
Oder kannst du dir locker ein paar Autos verkaufen.
Und ich glaube,
die Dell-Kisten, die wir haben,
die sind...
Also es gibt welche
mit 2TB RAM.
Das sind die für Virtualisierungsgedöns.
Die anderen weiß ich ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht, was die für Specs haben, die im
Oktober kommen.
Das ist alles.
Was meintest du denen hier?
Das hier? Nein, das ist kein NAS.
Das ist ein...
Ich bin gerade HP.
Das ist kein NAS, das ist ein Playcenter.
Da gibt es von IBM schöne
Fotos, wo man sieht, was das ist.
Genau.
Genau, das sind die alten IBM
Playcenter. Das ist im Prinzip
ein Gehäuse.
Da ist intern alles Mögliche drin. Hier unten
sind Zwitscher drin.
Hinten unten sind Zwitscher drin.
Glasfaser,
Saan-Anschlüsse,
Management-Geschichten
sind in diesem Gehäuse drin.
Und du schiebst halt vorne, schiebst du so kleine
Plates rein. Das sind quasi...
Das da ist im Endeffekt ein Server.
Man darf sich hier nicht mit 200 Euro täuschen lassen.
Das sind die alten HS22...
Die haben übrigens auch schon 96 GB
RAM-Defaulten.
Das sind die alten HS22
von IBM.
Die kosten neu auch Kleinwagengröße.
Und
davon kannst du halt 16...
Meistens 16 oder in dem Fall 12
waren es, glaube ich, bei allen reinmachen.
Also sprich, du hast halt dieses
Gehäuse und du schiebst dann halt, je nachdem,
was du für Server brauchst, schiebst du rein.
Die sind kleiner als normale 1 HE-Kisten.
Ja, so sahen die
ganz alten aus.
Die...
Das waren noch Zeiten, wo ich...
Wo habe ich euch doch mal erzählt, wo ich
beim Provider gearbeitet habe und ab und zu
im Rechenzentrum war. So waren solche Dinger da drin.
HS20,
genau.
Das ist schon ganz coole Technik.
Ja, hier sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut.
Hier hinten hast du Switches drin.
Alter, kann das da unten mal weggehen?
Hier hinten
hast du Switche drin und hast
Storage-Anschlüsse, Fiber Channel,
Glasfaser.
Ist heute im Prinzip immer noch so, ja.
Sodass die ein bisschen moderner aussehen
von den Anschlüssen her. Man muss generell
sagen, so die Technik im
Rechenzentrum, das ist
alles recht
konservativ, ja.
Also da findest du auch durchaus
VGA-Anschlüsse und sowas.
Die sind da nicht so
scharf drauf, jetzt alles super modern
zu machen.
Also ich gehe mal davon
aus, dass die neuesten
HP-Kisten
vielleicht haben die
einen Displayport, aber ich
würde mich nicht drauf
verlassen, ja. Ich würde wahrscheinlich
eher drauf tippen, die haben immer noch VGA.
Gucken wir mal.
DL,
wie heißen die Dinger da denn? Was sind die aktuelle Generation?
Gen 10? Weiß
es gar nicht.
Ja, so
in der Größenordnung sind
die Kisten, die wir kriegen im Oktober.
So ungefähr
in der...
sieht da übrigens abgespacet
aus, die Dinger.
Ok, gucken wir mal, ob die schon...
VGA, sag ich doch, Leute!
Ist das doch VGA?
Ich mein, das ist ein fucking 61.000
Euro teurer Server.
Und was ist dran, Hine?
VGA!
Aber das ist normal.
Das ist normal.
Die sind da wirklich sehr konservativ.
Und das Schöne an VGA ist,
und das ist auch der Grund,
warum wahrscheinlich ganz viele
noch richtig lange VGA machen werden,
dass die, dass die
Onboard, diese Onboard-Management
Controller, die sind halt
uralt. Die sind wirklich
uralt. Da sind Grafikkarten
drauf.
Da sind solche Grafikkarten drauf.
ATI 3D Rage
Pro von...
was weiß ich von wann das Ding
ist? 1995
oder so.
So Grafikkarten hast du da noch drauf
auf den, auf den
Management-Controllern von den, von den neuen
Servern. So richtig
uralter Crap. Deswegen ist es
VGA und der hauptsächliche
Grund, warum auch in nächster Zeit VGA
bleiben wird, ist,
dass viele Rechenzentrum
KVM
Verkabelung,
Installationen haben. Also sprich, du hast
dann irgendwo einen Technikraum
und du
stöpselst dann halt an einen Server
einen Kabel an und gehst in deinen Technikraum
und hast dann halt
das auf dem Monitor vom Server.
Und das ist halt alles VGA.
Da kannst du kein HDMI oder so drüber machen.
Wobei ich ja persönlich früher,
als ich noch viel im Rechenzentrum
war, bin ich gerne
mit dem, mit dem Wagen an die Kisten
hin.
Ich bin immer mit dem Monitorwagen an die
Kisten.
Ich weiß nicht, ich fand das irgendwie netter.
Warum werden so alte Grafikkarten verwendet?
Weil die Teil vom, vom
Onboard-Management-Controller sind
und diese Controller sind halt
einfach da. Und die tun
und da sieht keiner den Grund das zu
Upgraden. So ein Management-Controller
hat
Ups.
What the fuck?
So ein Management-Controller
hat
Remote-Geschichten.
Ja, also du kannst beispielsweise dann
über den Web-Interface drauf und hast
den, also die haben ja
auch hier geguckt, das da ist der Management
Port. Da schließt du dann
quasi ein Kabel an, ganz normalen Netzwerk.
Das Ding hat quasi ein komplettes
Management-Interface, wenn du drauf gehst, wo du
Isos mounten kannst,
Betriebssystem drüber installieren kannst,
irgendwelche Daten
auswerten und sonst was. Also
und diese, diese, diese
Management-Controller sind halt
nicht die neuesten.
Die haben jetzt erst angefangen,
muss man sich ja mal überlegen. Die haben jetzt erst
angefangen, so sagt so, in den letzten
paar Jahren haben die erst angefangen,
dass die Web-Interfaces
HTML5 können.
Du musst, du musst bei manchen Kisten
heute noch Java installieren,
dass du, dass du nen Remote-
Web-Interface verwenden kannst.
Wie gesagt, die ganzen
Server-Rechenzentrum-Geschichten,
die sind sehr konservativ,
was das alles angeht.
Kannst du mal zeigen, was du mit China zeugt,
was nach Hause telefonieren will, meinst?
Und wo du die ROMs zum Flaschen hergekriegt hast?
Die ROMs zum Flaschen,
äh, ja das hier.
Wie ist das Ding?
Cogeek?
Leute, wisst ihr noch, wie der Kram hieß?
Cogeek, ne?
So, das hier ist doch die...
Wo ist denn mal eine Steckdosenleiste von mir?
Ja, sowas hier zum Beispiel.
Sowas haben wir geflasht.
Da haben wir, ähm,
da haben wir, ähm,
also das ist halt so ein
fertiges China-Ding.
Und da haben wir
das da drauf geflasht.
Da haben wir das Motor drauf geflasht.
Das sieht dann so aus
im Web-Interface.
Dann hast du dann ein Web-Interface auf deinem,
auf deiner Steckdosenleiste, wo du dann
quasi die einzelnen Steckdosen an-
und ausschalten kannst und sowas.
Und der Vorteil ist halt, die China
Firmware ist runter.
Und, ähm, du hast halt
nicht mehr den Zwang,
die offizielle China App auf dem
Smartphone verwenden zu müssen.
Sondern kannst das ganz normal über Web-Interface
über irgendwas machen, wie du willst.
Ey, das ist nicht für jeden was.
Aber ich verwende so wenig
China-Geräte mit Original-Firmware, wie es
geht.
Wie ist das jetzt mit Java eigentlich
im Unternehmen? Ist immer noch saumäßig
verbreitet. Die meiste Business-Software
ist in Java und wird auch in Zukunft in Java
gemacht.
Was für Interfaces unterstützen
mittlerweile HTML, äh,
HTML5 von Dell? Die
Dell-Kisten können mittlerweile HTML5.
Die können aber auch noch, äh,
Java
und jetzt haltet euch fest,
die können auch noch ActiveX.
Kann man auswählen,
was man für einen Remote verwenden will.
ActiveX, Java oder
HTML5. Ich weiß nicht,
ist Dell
ILO? Nee, ILO ist glaube ich HP.
RSA ist IBM.
Äh...
Fuck, wie ist das Dell-Ding?
Das Lizenzmodell
von Java ist egal. Du kannst
einfach das OpenJDK verwenden.
Äh, wie...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das Dell...
Okay, IBM
ist RSA, HP ist ILO
und Dell ist...
iDRAC, iDRAC, genau,
iDRAC
ist aber iDRAC.
Aber ich sag immer iDRAC.
Ähm, stimmt, das ist die
Geschichte von Dell. Ja, ich...
Die Namen kann man sich mal schlecht merken.
Jo. Genau, wie gesagt hier,
alles VGA, ne?
Ich mein, die haben ja
hier anscheinend schon... Warte mal,
hab ich da grad USB 3 gesehen
und hab mich da verguckt, das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Das...
Ist das wirklich USB 3?
Ich mein, USB 3 kam
nur 2010 raus.
Das ist für
so Serveranbieter schon
richtig next level, dass da ein USB...
Ups, ein USB 3.
Ja, sorry,
nicht USB 3.
USB 3.2 Generation
2x2, natürlich,
ja.
Ja, und was man zu solchen Serverkisten auch sagen muss,
ist... So fett!
Was man zu solchen Serverkisten
auch sagen muss, wenn man es hier hinten aufmacht,
ähm...
Die Bauweise bietet natürlich
schon Vorteile. Da passen
immer relativ viele Erweiterungskarten rein.
Also bei 4HE-Kisten, ja. Bei anderen
müsstest du es so machen, da passt nicht mehr so viel rein.
Aber du kannst ja immer ziemlich
viele Dinger reinstöpseln, wenn du willst.
Und das ist halt auch
das, was es irgendwie so teuer macht. Der Kram ist halt
auch getestet. Also...
Sagen wir mal so, der sollte
getestet sein und wenn es Probleme gibt, musst du halt den Support
nerven, aber in der Regel
ist es schon darauf ausgelegt, dass
wenn du da was kaufst, du kannst da halt auch wirklich
in jeden PCI-Express-
Slot kannst du halt auch eine Karte reinstecken
und das Ding funktioniert.
Und selbst wenn ihr 2 oder 3,
wahrscheinlich 2, je nachdem, Netzteile
verrecken, geht das Ding halt immer noch.
Die können ein paar Ports verrecken, ist
auch egal, der Kram geht immer noch.
Also wenn du es richtig eingestellt hast, natürlich, ja.
Du kannst Remote hier über das
Management-Interface, ich vermute mal, dass es Management-Interface
ist, kannst ja drauf zugreifen. Also...
Server-Hardware ist nicht
ganz umsonst
so teuer.
Und...
Man muss aber auch sagen,
für den Heimbereich ist es maßlos
überdimensioniert, weil, wie gesagt,
meine Kiste hier oben,
die will ich jetzt ja auch gerade deswegen ersetzen,
weil sie halt so krass überdimensioniert ist.
Das ist jetzt halt
Selbstbau gewesen,
hat aber auch ein Management-Interface und alles,
ist natürlich bei WeChat nicht so
getestet, wie das eine Dell-Kiste ist.
Auf dem neuen Ding läuft ja auch
Home-Automation. Was planst du dafür?
Weil, wie gesagt, so eine
Jiminy-Lake-Board.
Auf der Kiste, das habe ich ja schon ausgelagert,
also es läuft auf der Kiste kaum noch was
wichtiges.
Auf der Kiste liefert früher alles.
Aktuell ist
Internet- und Firewall-
Routingzeugs ist runter,
Heimautomatisierung ist runter,
das einzige wichtige, was eigentlich noch
drauf ist auf der Kiste,
ist das Nass.
Und der TV-Server.
Das sind die zwei einzigen wichtigen Sachen,
die noch drauf sind. Das heißt, die Kiste kann jetzt eigentlich
weg, wenn es umgestellt ist.
Dazu brauche ich aber erst noch ein passendes
Board.
Wo hattest du dein Selbstbau-Management-
Interface? Ja gar nicht, das ist...
Das Board hat ein Management-Interface.
Und was hast du dann jetzt für den neuen Server
als Hardware?
Ein...
S-Rock?
Also wie gesagt, wir
sind hier qualitätsmäßig
schon ganz schön der Abstieg.
Ein S-Rock...
So ein Ding.
So ein Ding habe ich jetzt.
Nicht ganz das.
Nicht ganz das Board, aber fast.
Hier.
Das da.
Das da habe ich jetzt.
Das ist aber...
Das ist ein stinknormales...
stinknormales...
ähm...
Low-Budget...
geringes Stromverbrauch
von Superboard.
Also von da
auf da
ist schon ein ganz schön mäßiger Abstieg.
Sowohl Hardware,
also sowohl Qualität, als auch
Stromverbrauch
und vor allem Leistung.
Leistung ist auf dem Ding hier natürlich
immens viel höher als auf dem da.
Aber das reicht prinzipiell.
Das einzige, warum ich es noch nicht
alles umgestellt habe ist,
weil ich aktuell zwei Kisten davon
hinstellen müsste. Ich brauche zwar immer
noch weniger Strom als das hier,
aber irgendwie
wieder strebt es mir zwei Kisten hinzustellen.
Das Problem ist nämlich,
dass die Dinger immer ein bisschen doof verteilt
sind, was ihre PCI-Express-Lanes
angeht.
Also ich brauche zwei
PCI-Express-Anschlüsse.
SATA-Ports ist gut,
aber die meisten verteilen es so ein bisschen an
sinnlose
Dinger.
Ich brauche PCI-Express
einfach und
PCI-Express zweifach.
Zweifach gibt es nicht, also das ist dann entweder ein 16 oder
ein 4er oder ein 8er Slot, ist mir egal.
Aber das sind die PCI-Lanes, die ich brauche.
Ich brauche einfach für die TV-Karte.
Ich brauche
mindestens zweifach
PCI-Express 2.0 für die
10G-Karte.
Und aktuell findest du halt
keine Boards
mit zwei PCI-Express-Anschlüssen.
Oder mit PCI-Express
und M2.
Das wäre auch okay. Das Problem ist,
das einzige Board, was es gibt,
mit PCI-Express
und einem M2-Slot
hat nur einen Dual-Core.
Und der Dual-Core im Mini-Lake
ist zu langsam für das, was ich machen will.
Der Quad-Core ist okay,
der Dual-Core ist zu langsam.
Der Dual-Core kackt dir schon ab,
wenn du 10G
Summer-File-Transfer machst.
Also, 10G.
Wir reden hier jetzt nicht 10G,
die wirklich drüber gehen.
Weil es ist eh nur PCI-Express 2.0
und nur zwei Lanes. Also sprich, das ist dann eh
theoretisch, glaube ich,
Maximum 800MB.
Ne, äh, 800MB oder so.
Aber es ist immer noch ordentlich.
Ja, deswegen, ich bräuchte
einen Board
mit M2,
PCI-Express
und einem Quad-Core.
Dann wäre ich voll ganz zufrieden.
Gibt's aber aktuell nicht.
Es gibt eins, allerdings haben die das nie hergestellt.
Die haben mega-gebated.
Ähm...
Warte, war das Gigabyte?
Giga...
Wie schreibt man die Dudes?
Doch so, ne?
I, I.
Geh weg.
Butterboards.
Wie kann man hier sortieren?
Embedded Butterboards.
Äh?
Ne?
Ah, hier.
Genau.
Das Board wäre...
Das Board wäre gut für mich.
PCI-Express einfach
für die TV-Karte.
M2-Slot
für die 10G-Karte.
Der ist nämlich auch mit
zweifach PCI-Express zweifach angebunden.
Und zwei SATA-Ports.
Das wäre perfekt für mich.
Das Problem ist,
dieses Board haben die angekündigt
und nie hergestellt.
Das gibt es nicht.
Das Board gibt es nicht.
Die haben gedacht,
es lohnt sich nicht zu bauen.
So ein Kack braucht keiner.
Ich würde es halt brauchen, ne?
Das wäre das perfekte Board für mich.
Für meine Kiste.
Da könnte ich alles in einer Kiste machen.
Äh, hey Max.
Was für einen DNS-Server nutzt du?
Ich habe Primary, Google
und Backup Cloudflare.
Cloudflare?
Ne, doch Cloudflare.
8888 und 1111.
Netzteile regelmäßig wechseln?
Wenn ja, wie oft? Gar nicht.
Warten bis es abbraucht.
Welche TV-Karte hast du?
Eine Quad-Tuner,
DVBC, Quad-
Win-TV, äh...
Die da, glaube ich.
Die mit PC-Express einfach.
Vernutzt du V-Sphere? Ne.
Der heimlich.
Äh, was mit dem alten Software?
Den behalte ich erstmal.
Den lasse ich hier stehen für Experimente.
Ja, und so ein Board bräuchte ich.
Das wäre perfekt.
Der hat sogar eine USB-3-Anschleuse.
Das wäre richtig gut, dieses Board.
Und ich hoffe, dass mit dem Gimini-Refresh
halt eins kommt,
was genau diese Ausstattung hat
und halt produziert wird.
Schreib die mal an.
Ja, wenn die es aber nie gebaut haben.
Und was ist bei dem Board mit RAM?
Wieso?
Ganz normaler DDR4-RAM.
Halt, halt, die
kurze, diese S0-
0-DIMM
oder so-DIMM, wie spricht man das eigentlich aus?
Gibt es die auch mit Ryzen? Nein.
Das ist ein Segment, da hat AMD
tatsächlich nichts zu bieten.
Desktop würde ich mir jetzt...
Also, wenn ich mir jetzt einen Desktop kaufe,
würde ich mir sofort einen Ryzen kaufen.
Aber in diesem Low-Power,
Low-Cost-Low-Power
Segment
hat AMD nichts aktuell.
Leute, fuck, es ist 22.10 Uhr.
Muss ins Bett.
Morgen wieder 5.45 Uhr aufstehen.
Kann Mikrotik OpenVPN
über IPv6?
Ich denke schon.
Also OpenVPN können sie.
Allerdings
hat mal jemand im Stream erzählt,
dass OpenVPN unter Mikrotik
richtig scheiße sein soll.
Ich kann es dir nicht
belegen, noch widerlegen,
weil ich habe es noch nicht verwendet.
Das kommt drauf an.
Ich mag
Manage-Switche.
Also, weil
zumindest die meisten etwas
advancedere Switche
ein Management-Interface haben.
Da kannst du
auch mal so etwas nachgucken,
wie viel Traffic
über diesen Port geht oder sonst was drüber.
Was du dir
überlegen musst für einen Switch
ist, erstens brauchst du
advancede Sachen wie WLAN-Unterstützung
oder
und brauchst du PoE.
Das ist das, was du dich fragen musst.
Brauchst du PoE?
Fragezeichen.
Und brauchst du WLAN-Unterstützung.
Wenn nicht,
nimm den billigsten
16-Port-Switch, den du bei Amazon
kriegst.
Wenn du was bisschen
besseres brauchst. Ach so, ja und wie schnell
er sein soll. Also,
ich vermute mal Gigabit.
Ein 16-Port-10G-Switch ist schon
eine ganze Ecke
teurer. Ein 16-Port-10G-Switch,
da bist du wahrscheinlich bei 2000 Euro
oder so.
Habe noch ein paar Ressourcen frei
auf meinem V-Swerber, hast du Ideen, die zu nutzen?
Pfff, wo soll ich das wissen?
Track dein iPhone.
So, gucken wir mal, 16-Port.
Was ist denn der günstigste hier?
Der ist ziemlich, der ist ziemlich
nice.
Den wollte ich mir sogar mal holen, den kann man tatsächlich
empfehlen. Das sind 24-Port-Switch
und das richtig gute an dem
ist, das ist aber nur,
das ist aber wirklich nur die Switch-Variante.
Da ist kein Router-OS drauf.
Der hat auch viel zu schwache CPU, um zu
rauten.
Das sind 24-Port-Switch
mit zwei
SFP-Plus Uplink-Ports
für 10G.
Also, das ist richtig gut das Ding
und der ist saumäßig günstig
für das, was er kann. Der ist wirklich saumäßig
günstig. Also, den kann ich empfehlen.
123 Euro ist geschenkt
für das Ding.
So, und wenn du ein bisschen mehr brauchst, kannst
du dir auch noch die Router-Variante kaufen.
Die Rauder-Variante.
Den da.
Der kostet dann 60 Euro
mehr. Nico abonniert
Stufe 1, Dankeschön.
Ich muss jetzt echt gleich
auf.
Das ist die bisschen teurere Variante.
Die hat
Router-OS-Unterstützung.
Da kannst du auch ein bisschen
advancedere Sachen machen. Allerdings muss man dazu sagen,
die Hardware in dem Ding
ist jetzt nicht so
nicht so der krasse Router hier.
Also, mein billiger
Hex-POE 5-Port-Router
routet ungefähr
doppelte
drüber
CPU-mäßig, als
was der packt, wie der hier.
Also,
für den halben Gebrauch ein bisschen routen ist okay.
Jetzt die super
Routing-Performance wirst du mit dem Ding nicht hinkriegen.
Guck mal, das schafft noch nicht mal Gigabit.
Nicht zu switchen, zu routen
wohlgemerkt. Deswegen
würde ich, ich würde mir die reine
Switch-Variante kaufen, ehrlich gesagt.
Einfach, weil man das Ding wahrscheinlich
eh nur als Switch verwendet.
Leute, ich kann nicht
weitermachen, ich muss pennen, sonst kann ich
morgen früh nicht aufstehen.
Wir sehen uns morgen,
spätestens morgen Abend mit dem Video.
Vielleicht bin ich danach auch noch mal on.
Merkt euch die Fragen, die ihr habt.
Kommt im nächsten Stream einfach wieder vorbei.
Und ich kann den ganzen Kram beantworten.
Ich muss jetzt echt pennen, sonst wird das nichts.
Machts gut, bis denn.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.